je suis fou de ton spectacle piaf un
carton et sache que j'étais un petit peu
déçu parce que moi je te kiffe grave et
j'ai vu que tu avais honte allez un
petit peu plage est un humoriste qui
s'appelle nardine gainey il avait sorti
le spectacle l'algérie rang 80 et je
trouve on a fait un montage des deux
spectacles
nous ça nous un petit peu choqués on
voudrait montrer aux téléspectateurs ce
soir regardez attendait à temps j'arrive
j'arrive qu'est ce qui à madame oui
c'est ça le pl oui ça se mange tes pas
contre n importe quelle belle
qu'est ce qui à madame c'est la mise
chaque manche qui pas contente elle
porte la halle babe police et souvent la
djellaba ten poche qui est pas cousue ça
leur donne accès directement la
marchandise
c'est leur boule anti stress
souvent lg labat à une poche qui est pas
cousu et petit jaune ils sont là s'est
déroulé du stress et quand je serai
grande je serai très très grande et je
ferai des spectacles c'est public il
rigole pas mes blagues d'une chambre
gamer et caen nice rennes grand qui
serait très très grand il vivrait
l'esprit de la décennie qui rigole pas
mes blagues échalas elie kakou et roland
magdane qu'il a vraiment tombé pascal
gires ça c'est un festival qui existe
déjà en algérie vraiment l'ubs à se
faire tabasser un mail à ses bottes très
très chaud bd légaux ou illégaux